for the last two and a half years I am
one of the few if not the only child
psychiatrist operating in refugee
accounts shore lines are rescue boats in
Greece and the Mediterranean Sea and I
can say with a great confidence that we
are witnessing a mental health
catastrophe that will affect most of us
and it will change our world I live in
Haifa but nowadays I spend most of my
time abroad during my time with the
Greek island of Lesbos and when the
rescue boats in the Mediterranean
thousands of refugee boats arrived to
the shoreline crowded with more than 1.5
million refugees fourth of them are
children fleeing war and hardship each
boat carries different sufferings and
traumas from Syria Iraq Afghanistan and
different countries in Africa in the
last three years alone more than 12,000
refugees lost their lives and hundred of
thousands lost their souls and their
mental health due to this cruel and
traumatic experience I want to tell you
about Omar a five year old Syrian
refugee boy who arrived to the shore of
lesbos on a crowded rubber boat crying
frightened unable to understand what's
happening to him he was right on the
verge of developing a new trauma
I knew right away that this was a golden
hour a short period of time in which I
could change his story I could change
the story that he would tell himself for
the rest of his life
I could refrain that his memories
I quickly held out my hands and say to
his shaking mother in Arabic RT near
wallet hood in AFER's give me the boy
and take a breath his mother gave him to
me
Omar looked at me with a scared tearful
eyes and say among Uncle in Arabic
Shahada what is this as he pointed out
to the police helicopter hovering above
us it's a helicopter it's here to
photograph you with big cameras because
only the great and the powerful heroes
like you Omer can cross the sea
Omar looked at me stopped crying and
asked me on a bottle I'm a hero
I talked to Omar for 15 minutes and I
gave his parents some guidance to follow
this short psychological intervention
decreases the prevalence of
post-traumatic stress disorder and other
mental health issues in the future
preparing gomber ticket and education
joined the workforce raise a family and
beyond
how by stimulating the good memories
that will be stored in the amygdala the
emotional storage of the human brain
these memories will fight the traumatic
ones if they are reactivated in the
future but Omar the smell of the sea
will not just remind him of his dramatic
journey from Syria because to Omar this
story is now a story of bravery this is
the power of the Golden Hour which can
reframe the trauma and establish a new
narratives but Omar is only one out of
more than 350,000 children without the
proper mental health support in this
crisis alone 350,000 children and me we
need mental health professionals to join
rescue teams during time of active
crisis this is why my wife and I and
friends co-founded humanity crew one of
the few aid organizations the world that
specialized in providing psychosocial
aid and first response mental health
interventions to refugees and displaced
populations to provide them with a
suitable intervention we create the
four-step approach a psychosocial war
plan that follow the refugees for each
step of their journey starting inside
the sea on the rescue boat as a mental
health lifeguards later in the camps
hospitals and through our online clinic
that breaks down borders and overcomes
languages and ending in the asylum
countries helping them integrate since
our first mission in 2015 humanity crew
had 194 delegation of qualified trained
volunteers and therapists
we have provided 26,000 hours of mental
health support to over 10,000 refugees
we can all do something to prevent this
mental health catastrophe we need to
acknowledge that first aid is not just
needed for the body but it has also to
include the mind the soul the impact on
the soul is hardly visible that the
damage can be there for life let's not
forget that what distinguishes us humans
from machines is the beautiful and the
delicate soul within us
let's try harder to save more armors
thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]